as nice et loire trouve enfin leurs
parents après des mois de séparation les
deux jeunes femmes étaient au maroc avec
eux lorsque les frontières ont été
fermées au mois de mars elles ont pu
trouver une place dans un des vols que
le gouvernement canadien a organisé pour
rapatrier ses ressortissants mais pas
leurs parents le maroc a coupé les
frontières dès le début donc ce qui fait
que tous les avions étaient annulés avec
la royal air maroc puis après ça les
rapatriements ils n'ont pas pu avoir de
billet nous on a été capable mais
derrière les masques portés par tous les
voyageurs ont deviné les grands sourires
des 290 canadien rapatriés et de leurs
proches après de longs mois
d'incertitude et de stress à ne pas
savoir quand il verrait de nouveau leurs
êtres chers
c'était difficile si on ne va pas se
cacher que y'a pas mieux que d'être avec
sa petite famille en plus elle est hélas
un simple c'est magnifique
après après six mois je les attends le
rapatriement est le fruit d'une
collaboration entre le canada et le
maroc
l'avion de royal air maroc qui a
rapatrié les canadiens est d'ailleurs
reparti avec à son bord 2 190 marocain
coincé à montréal certains canadiens
dénonce les longs mois de délai depuis
la fermeture des frontières en raison de
la pandémie avant que les membres de
leur famille pu revenir
moi je trouve que les mesures que le
gouvernement a pressé m pas vraiment
assez tu vois c'était un petit peu comme
ils ont laissé les gens l'abandon un
petit peu mais le plus important
aujourd'hui pour ces familles c'est
d'être finalement réunies car j'avais
presque une dépression ça c'est sur des
baies de trèbes de pression je dormais
pas durant presque à moi j'ai pas dormi
c'est vraiment extraordinaire de
retrouver sa maison ses enfants ses
petits enfants pour nous
les canadiens qui sont de retour de pro
maintenant respecter une quarantaine 14
jours avant de reprendre leur vie là où
il l'avait laissé
il serre émis authier radio canada
montréal